[Music]
day in and day out you're using one of
the biggest machines in the world and
you may not even know it it's in your
home it lines the streets and it's
powered by gigantic engines across the
country the biggest machine in the world
isn't this or this or even this it's the
electrical power grid or more
specifically the u.s. power grid in the
United States alone the grid contains
enough high voltage wiring to wrap
around the earth six times over and
that's not including all the low voltage
wiring running through our streets and
into our homes this entire system was
built in a little over 100 years and
since then we've become very accustomed
to having electricity available to us at
the flip of a switch but before this
machine existed here only sources of
light by night were lanterns and candles
and nearly all our daily chores needed
to be done by hand this giant machine
started pretty small was the world's
first central power station built on Pro
Street Manhattan in 1882 Thomas Edison
the ever-present American businessman
some opportunity to not only sell more
of his light bulbs but to sell the
electricity to power them too so he
built an electric generator driven by a
coal powered steam engine to create
electricity at a cost that would allow
his lightbulbs to compete with lanterns
the station contained six of these
generators each producing 100 kilowatts
enough to power 1,200 of Edison's light
bulbs allowing Edison to sell 7,200
volts which needed to be replaced
regularly as these light bulbs lasted
about 1,200 hours even then the project
ran an operating loss for its first two
years setting up this system was a bold
businessman the machines conduits and
the 30 kilometers of wiring needed for
it were expensive at a cost of three
hundred thousand dollars or about twenty
million dollars in today's money the
expensive lower Manhattan real estate
didn't help either
but Edison's placement of the Pro Street
Station was vital to the success of the
idea as it had the population density to
make the project financially viable so
they also made one of his first
customers the New York Times who
published a story about the historic
event reporting that the light was soft
mellow and graceful to the eye without a
flicker to make the head ache this was
all the marketing Edison needed and
and for the system grew but this point
about one of the system's major flaws it
couldn't scale economically without
installing more power stations nearby
because it generated a low voltage
direct current to efficiently transfer
power over long distance we need to
transform the low voltage to a higher
voltage the power loss equation states
the power loss in transmission equals
the current squared multiplied by the
resistance of the wire and so to reduce
power loss we really need to minimize
the current this equation describes the
relationship between power transmitted
and the voltage and current the
community demand fix the amount of power
required and so to decrease the current
we need to increase the transmission
voltage alternating currents main
advantage over direct current isn't that
it loses less power over long distance
pathetic can be transformed from low
voltage to high voltage much more
efficiently than direct current the
demand for power grew across the nation
the famed argument between Edison's idea
to have many smaller generators located
near population centers and Nikola
Tesla's idea of having one large
efficient engine located far from
population centers grew of course we
know who won and today we have hundreds
of gigantic power stations located far
from population centers generating
gigawatts of power so what would a map
of the current US electrical grid look
like let's create a map showing the
largest power plants across the u.s. in
areas where rainfall is high like
Washington State on the west coast and
Alabama in the south there's a howl you
move electrons with hydro power or wind
speeds are highest in Central America
there is a growing number of wind
turbines States that get the most Sun
like California and Arizona I'm the
highest percentage of solar power there
are several high powered nuclear power
plants located in areas where water is
plentiful which is needed for the steam
turbines and to cool their course coal
power plants tend to be close to coal
money as it's a very heavy fuel but the
largest percentage of energy in the u.s.
is generated from natural gas as it's
the cleanest of the fossil fuel let's
zoom in on one of these power plants to
get an idea of how this energy is
delivered to population centers as I
mentioned earlier it's vital that
electricity is transmitted at high
voltage so the first step as the
electricity exits the power plant is to
pass through a step-up transformer the
electricity is then delivered across
these high-voltage power lines that you
see stretching across the country these
powerlines feed into local step-down
transformers for local distribution in
neighborhoods and gets stepped down
again why these transformer drums and
poles outside your house the electricity
you consume in your house is measured on
a meter like this that reads the power
running through the wire that enters
your house so let's say after a long
day's work you come home and decide you
want to watch the premiere episode of
Game of Thrones you plug in your viewing
device of choice and that meter starts
to take a little bit fasting along with
millions of other meters across the
nation suddenly the biggest machine in
the world just got a little bigger and
the engines powering it have to work
harder to keep up with that demand this
is one of the huge disadvantages of the
current power grid during low demand
hours we have a number of always on
power plants called base load plants
they are powered by reliable energy
sources like coal and nuclear these
maintained the base load requirements of
the country but what happens if one of
these power stations fail suddenly the
system doesn't have enough energy to
meet demand and if we don't have the
ability to meet it power stations will
begin rolling blackouts where they cut
the electricity to certain areas to
prevent a larger blaka one of the
largest of these rolling blackouts to
ever occur was the 2003 northeastern
blaka
that left 15 million people without
electricity modern countries will have
money redundant power sources that can
be brought online when power demand
surges or power stations go down an
excellent communication between all
parts of the grid to ensure problems can
be fixed immediately
but as renewable sources like wind and
solar become more popular this
micromanagement of the power grid is
becoming even more difficult we cannot
command the weather to make these power
sources work harder when needed and the
more likely scenario is that we have to
shut down these power sources well they
could be generating energy because they
are generating energy that is not needed
which can overload the system it's
unlikely that we will be able to rely on
renewable energy without still having
many baseload power plants running on
natural gas coal or nuclear unless we
can create an efficient way of saving
this energy during peak performance for
later use when the demand is there
currently the largest energy storage
method worldwide is hydroelectricity at
about 80% on some days of the year
Denmark generates so much energy from
wind that they have enough to export to
countries like Norway who often use the
advantage of their mountainous terrain
to buy cheap access
power to pump water to the top of
mountains this water can then be
released to power hydroelectric turbines
when it's needed of course this leads to
some power loss but it's better than
shutting down the wind turbines while
they're at peak performance this issue
is only going to grow a solar energy
becomes more and more popular
which is why tesla powerwall is such an
integral part of making widespread home
installed solar power a reality we
cannot store the excess energy generated
by these panels during the day for use
when there isn't sunlight and then we
are still going to depend highly on
those baseload power plants using fossil
fuels or nuclear energy as the price of
manufacturing solar panels decreases
it's inevitable that all countries will
begin to move away from the current
model of the power grid we are on the
brink of a world-changing moment and the
largest machines in the world are going
to change drastically for the better
large fossil fuel power plants
generating AC electricity are quickly
becoming outdated and will be gradually
decommissioned over the next couple of
decades and a new model for the power
grid will rise in its place we will be
gradually moving towards Thomas Edison's
early vision of having many local low
voltage power generators creating DC
power but with a modern twist they will
all be powered by nothing more than the
energy we can draw from the ever
replenishing pool that nature has
provided us oh yeah thanks for watching
so this week I wanted to take you for a
walk and tell your story I'm it's
currently smelling and go away and this
is an old ring force so the force thing
kept cows ages the Lycans near my house
so was the telling story about when I'm
starting this channel I'm using a really
crappy laptop as old it was like four or
five years old
wasn't really capable of doing animation
definitely wasn't capable of doing my
animations and it broke down like three
times while I was using it I ended up
losing a lot of oil and I couldn't
afford to buy new one so I just kept on
having to like rebooted and started from
scratch occasionally I had files saved
to my cloud services that was ok but it
didn't do much for me when I had files
saved locally and that's what this
week's sponsors for so this week is
sponsored by Backblaze and black plays
are an incredible site of using
for a little while now and they're only
$5 a month which allows you to back up
all your files automatically and in the
case where case scenario when something
actually does happen and you lose on the
data on your computer you can go back
download files individually or you can
download all of them at the same time or
if your computer is this completely
wrecked like mine was you can get the
option of downloading a hard drive
instead and if you don't want the hard
drives in the Slender back so that's
five dollars a month or you can use the
link below which is Barclays comm for it
/ engineering for a 15 day trial it
seems like a pretty good deal right I
suggest you do it and I'll support the
channel tell them I sent you I'm just
going to show you some scenes from the
beautiful West of Ireland
Norfolk Georgie ah ah oh [ __ ]
you